c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion que
christine boutin a pris connaissance des
premiers résultats
elle reçoit 78% des voix dans sa commune
de charquemont qui comme ville où elle a
longtemps été maire à laquelle elle
reste profondément attaché je suis
fidèle à mes terres c'est de l'émotion
c'est celle du stress aussi vous l'avez
compris ce qu'on attend des résultats
donc voilà mais je voulais tu ici et pas
entre pas à son domicile
sa mère sa famille centralise les
résultats des soutiens indéfectibles
nous sommes satisfaits je suis
satisfaite je veux ya beaucoup
d'émotions soir vous l'aurez compris
parce que je suis ici chez moi avec ma
famille mes amis et je leur dis merci
une soirée pleine de suspense pour la
candidate
vers 21h les résultats ton pour le
canton de mèche christine bouquin
récolte 71% des voix mais avec
l'abstention il lui en manque 228 pour
être élu au premier tour
nous allons poursuivre l'ensemble de nos
actions vous avez compris quand nous
sommes devant comme ceux ci c'est
l'abstention qui nous a fait trébucher
donc on va recommencer dès demain matin
et aller chercher un par un les
électeurs pour que nous puissions mener
notre programme pour les six ans d une
mobilisation que la présidente sortante
du doubs espère d'envergure la semaine
prochaine la vraie victoire
[Applaudissements]